>> Tucker: MORE EVIDENCE TONIGHT
THAT IT'S ALWAYS THE PEOPLE YOU
MOST SUSPECT.
ANDREW CUOMO GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK IS EVERY BIT THE CREEP YOU
THOUGHT HE WAS AND MORE.
TALKS LIKE A MAFIA LEADER AND
ACT LIKE ONE.
11 SEXUAL HARASSMENT CLAIMS
AGAINST HIM PUBLIC TODAY.
GO TO CNN RIGHT NOW AND WATCH
JEFFREY TOOBIN OF ALL PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT HOW CREEPY GOVERNOR
CUOMO IS.
THIS COUNTRY COULD NOT GET
BETTER.
A LOT MORE ON THAT.
FIRST TONIGHT WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT" COMING TO YOU
FROM BUDAPEST, HUNGARY.
LAST SUMMER AS THE COVID
PANDEMIC RAGED THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES PEOPLE WHO READ
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" NOTICED
SOMETHING STRANGE.
HUNDREDS OF ARTICLES GOING BACK
DECADES DISAPPEARED.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" CONSIDERS
ITSELF A LIVING HISTORICAL
RECORD AND MAINTAINED SEARCHABLE
ARCHIVES GOING BACK BEFORE THE
CIVIL WARS BUT ARTICLES
DISAPPEARED.
WHAT WAS IN THOSE ARTICLES.
EVERY ONE WAS A PROPAGANDA PIECE
PAID FOR BY THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
YOU ARE SEEING ONE ON YOUR
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
WHY WOULD THE "NEW YORK TIMES,"
AMERICA'S PAPER OF RECORD, PRINT
PROPAGANDA FROM THIS REGIME AND
PRETEND IT WAS A NEWS ARTICLE?
FOR MONEY.
FINANCIAL FILINGS SHOW THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" MADE MORE THAN
$100,000 A MONTH FROM THIS
GARBAGE.
THOSE PAYMENTS WERE NOT
DISCLOSED.
THEY WERE HIDDEN FROM "NEW YORK
TIMES" READERS AND ONLY
UNCOVERED BY THE WASHINGTON FREE
BEACON.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WAS NOT THE
ONLY ORGANIZATION THAT DID THIS.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY PAID
$20 MILLION TO THE "L.A. TIMES"
AND THE CHICAGO TRIBUNE AND THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
TWITTER ALSO RECEIVED CHECKS
FROM THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
TOTALING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS.
THESE ARRANGEMENTS CONTINUED FOR
YEARS.
LAST SUMMER THEY STOPPED
ABRUPTLY.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" TRIED TO
HIDE THE EVIDENCE IT EVER
HAPPENED.
WHY?
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WON'T SAY.
WE DO NOT DISCUSS REVENUE BEYOND
OUR QUARTER-FINAL EARNINGS
REPORT.
WE KEPT LOOKING.
FIRST HERE IS SOME CONTEXT FOR
WHAT THE "NEW YORK TIMES" DID.
THIS IS WHAT MAINSTREAM NEWS
COVERAGE IN THE UNITED STATES
LOOKED LIKE MOST OF LAST YEAR.
SEE IF YOU CAN TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS AND WHAT
YOU MIGHT SEE ON CHINESE STATE
TELEVISION.
>> THE PRESIDENT REFERRED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS AS A FOREIGN VIRUS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO COME
ACROSS TO A LOT OF AMERICANS AS
SMACKING OF XENOPHOBIA.
>> HE THINKS THE ONLY PATH NOW
IS TO DECLARE THE VIRUS PUBLIC
ENEMY 1 AND PAINT IT IN RACIST
TERMS.
>> THE XENOPHOBIA AND THE RACISM
IS A COMMON THING AND IT'S
DANGEROUS.
IT'S A PROBLEM AND IT'S SCARY.
I WANT TO CALL THAT OUT.
>> WHY DO YOU KEEP CALLING THIS
THE CHINESE VIRUS?
IT'S RACIST.
>> IT'S NOT RACIST AT ALL.
NOT AT ALL.
IT COMES FROM CHINA.
THAT'S WHY.
>> Tucker: AS THIS VIRUS EMERGED
FROM CENTRAL CHINA TO KILL
AMERICANS IN HUGE NUMBERS AND
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WEST, NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY
MADE THE SAME AGGRESSIVELY
PRO-CHINA NOISE.
POLIT CO HIRED A FULL-TIME
SHILLS FOR HEADLINES LIKE THIS:
THE AMERICAN SYSTEM FAULTERED.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENCE FROM WHAT
THE CHINESE WOULD RIGHT ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
IT'S NOT DIFFERENT?
THE AMERICAN MEDIA WERE
HYSTERICAL ON THE QUESTION OF
WHERE THE CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM.
UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES WERE YOU
ALLOWED TO ENTERTAIN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT COVID 19 CAME
FROM A LAB IN WUHAN, CHINA.
THAT WAS A CONSPIRACY THREO.
ALL OF THIS FOOTAGE IS FROM
EARLY 2020--
>> ROBERT REDFIELD BELIEVES
COVID 19 ORIGINATES FROM A LAB
IN WUHAN EVEN THOUGH THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE THEORY.
>> THE LAB LEAK IS NOT
A PLAUSIBLE THEORY.
>> THE THEORY THAT THE VIRUS
ORIGINATED IN A LAB IN WUHAN,
CHINA.
BUT DR. FAUCI SAID THIS VIRUS
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN ARTIFICIALLY
MANIPULATED.
>> SCIENTISTS AGREES THIS
CORNERS WAS NOT MAN MADE.
IT CAME FROM A NATURAL SOURCE,
NOT FROM A LAB.
>> PEOPLE LIKE THE PHRASE ESCAPE
FROM A LAB.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT A MAN MADE VIRUS THAT
CHINA WAS WEAPONIZING THAT GOT
OUT OF CONTROL.
>> Tucker: IT WASN'T JUST DUMB
PEOPLE ON CABLE NEWS.
THAT WAS ANTHONY FAUCI AND SCOTT
GOTTLIEB WHO RAN THE FDA.
THESE ARE PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF
AUTHORITY AND RESPECTED AS
SCIENTISTS WHOSE WORD CARRIES
GREAT MORAL WEIGHT.
THEY ALL LIED.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" LED THE WAY
ON THIS.
A PIECE ON UNHEARD.COM
DECONSTRUCTS THE "NEW YORK
TIMES"'S ROLL ON THE PROPAGANDA
EFFORT ON BEHALF OF CHINA.
THE "TIMES" DISMISSED THE LAB
LEAK THEORY AS A FRINGE THEORY.
ONLY LUNATICS BELIEVE IT.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER
CALLED THE THEORY THE KIND OF
CONSPIRACY ONCE RESERVED FOR THE
TINFOIL HATTERS.
YOU ARE A NUT CASE IF YOU THINK
IT'S POSSIBLE.
THEN THE PAPER PUBLISHED AN
OP-ED BY THE VIROLOGIST PAID BY
ANTHONY FAUCI TO EXPERIMENT ON
BAT CORONAVIRUSES.
TALK ABOUT A CONFLICT OF
INTERESTS.
HE DENYED IT CAME FROM A LAB HE
WAS FUNDING.
HE KNEW BETTER -- HE BLAMED THE
PANDEMIC ON DEFORESTATION, IN
OTHER WORDS ON POOR PEOPLE.
LIES LIKE THIS BECAME LESS
TENABLE.
PEOPLE NOTICED THAT A LEVEL 4
VIROLOGY WORLD IN WUHAN WAS
CONDUCTING DANGEROUS EXPERIMENTS
ON BAT CORONAVIRUSES WITH FEWER
SAFE GUARDS THAN A DENTIST
OFFICE HAS IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY TOYED THAT TONY FAUCI
HELPED TO PAY FOR THOSE
EXPERIMENTS.
THAT'S WHEN THE "TIMES" DELETED
THE ARTICLES.
TWO HIGH LEVEL EMPLOYEES SAID
THE PAPER STOPPED ANY
INVESTIGATION INTO EVIDENCE THAT
THE CORONAVIRUS CAME FROM THAT
LAB IN WUHAN.
ONE WHISTLEBLOWER SAID I
SUGGESTED WE INVESTIGATE THE
ORIGINS OF COVID.
I WAS TOLD IT WAS DANGEROUS TO
RUN A PIECE ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
THE CORONAVIRUS.
THERE WAS RESISTANCE TO RUNNING
ANYTHING THAT COULD SUGGEST
COVID 19 WAS MAN MADE OR LEAKED
FROM THE LAB.
IT WAS UNTOUCHABLE FROM
EVERYWHERE SAID ANOTHER "TIMES"
SOURCE.
THE FACT THAT TRUMP EMBRACED IT
MADE IT A NO GO.
ACCORDING TO WHISTLEBLOWERS THE
BIGGEST FACTOR WAS THE FACT THAT
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WAS TAKING
MONEY FROM THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
GOVERNMENT.
SO THEY CALLED THE STORY THAT
WAS NOT A THEORY BUT REAL.
THE HOUSE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS ESCAPED FROM THE LAB
IN WUHAN IN DECEMBER 2019.
ATHLETES FROM AROUND THE WORLD
WERE IN WUHAN AND BROUGHT COVID
HOME WITH THEM.
WHY DIDN'T WE KNOW THIS?
BECAUSE OF A LYING CAMPAIGN ON
BEHALF OF THE GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA.
PETER WHO IS STILL USED BY THE
"WASHINGTON POST" AS AN
AUTHORITY ON THE ORIGIN OF
COVID.
THEY DESCRIBE HIM AS THE PUBLIC
FACE OF A CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN
DESIGNED TO SUPPRESS PUBLIC
DISCUSSION ABOUT A LAB LEAK.
THE COMMITTEE DISCOVERED
EVIDENCE THAT THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY SOUGHT
BIDS FOR 2 CONTRACTS IN 2019.
ONE WAS VERY A SECURITY SERVICE
PROCUREMENT PROJECT ISSUED ON
SEPTEMBER 12th.
SEPTEMBER 12th WAS THE SAME DAY
THAT THE WOULD YOU KNOW WOULD
YOU KNOW LAB ABRUPTLY TOOK ITS
VIRUS DATABASE OFF LINE.
4 DAYS LATER THE WUHAN LAB
ANNOUNCED ANOTHER CONTRACT
COMPETITION.
FOR A $600-MILLION EFFORT TO
RENOIVATE THE LAB'S AIR
CONDITIONING SYSTEM.
-- RENOIVATE.
WHY?
THE "TIMES" DISPATCH FROM
BEIJING, ALL EVIDENCE OF THOSE
CONTRACT WERE WIPED FROM THE
WEBSITE OF CHINA.
JOHN RATCLIFF IS THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND WROTE AN OP-ED
THAT INCLUDE THIS ASSESSMENT:
THE LAB LEAK THEORY IS NOT JUST